so we are live on hello everyone uh
welcome to this session of the Berlin
science week my name is Martin Ram I'm
the coordinator of green cam uh as well
as the Director of the chemic invention
Factory and what that exactly is you
will hopefully know exactly by the end
of my talk um but before going into
detail
uh maybe a little personal introduction
about my myself that you get to know me
a little bit better um in my private
life I'm very engaged for Environmental
Protection I'm the first or the
president of an NGO that is uh qualified
by the um bundes so the uh Federal
Agency for Environmental Protection and
we do reiteration work here in
Brandenburg so characterized my
personality is more or less I love what
I do and I do what I love and I'm an
entrepreneur I'm really engaged for
Environmental Protection not only in my
private life but also in my professional
life and that is what I will talk about
today I will talk about two main topics
about chemistry as the title says and
about Innovation and a special type of
innovation and
disruption
um for the next 1 hour and 50 minutes
approximately uh we will have like three
parts of this session first of all I
will give you like a 20 minute talk
about those two topics my viewpoint on
it where do we stand in terms of
innovation what is the disruptive
innovation Where Do We Stand uh in
chemistry what is green chemistry
basically why do we need it what role do
startups
play um yeah and and what Berlin has to
offer here in this in in this uh in this
circumstance so to speak then afterwards
we will I will welcome one of our
startups in our ecosystem wild Stephanie
is also here she will give a like what
is called the pitch a very short PR
presentation of her startup uh and then
we will have a Q&A because what I will
talk about I think it's much more
profound if we discuss if that's really
not only my perception but also viewed
by the startups I'm I'm helping to
become
successful okay uh throughout the
session uh we have planned to be very
interactive uh this is in in basically
three ways first of all we use slider so
every one of you I suppose has a mobile
phone has smartphone there will be some
QR codes I you will see that clearly and
I want to go into interaction using that
tool second of all if you have any
question if something is not
understandable um yeah please raise your
hand or we have some microphones here um
um and then yeah I will try to or we
will try to answer your questions this
is also live streamed so please use the
microphones um and last but not least at
the end we would love to hear about your
opinion about your perception of today's
talk and and the session here what do
you like where do you see improvements
that's the that's the three parts of
interaction okay so far to the setting
um let's get into the topic a little in
terms of chemistry who of you guys is a
chemist or is working in a chemistry
room related field first question please
hand sign okay that's I see like 1 two 3
four five 6 Seven 8 nine Nish 10ish
that's approximately I'd say like 30
people that's oneir it's quite a lot
actually if you compare the average uh
uh in our country um second of all okay
that's good um I will not talk very much
in detail about chemistry I basically
only have one molecule um um I forgot
something I only got one molecule uh in
my slide that's for next slide but um so
we here in the bird's room right and my
first hypothesis is chemistry is
everywhere and we sat together in the
team and thought about okay where do we
correlate where do can we bond with
birds right and as and we had we came up
in a short brainstorm session uh and we
saw many things first of all um like
color color color or the coloration of
those beautiful birds this is basically
chemistry and physics but lots and lots
of chemistry but I thought but this is
too complicated then second of all those
are exhibits right is unfortunately dead
animals so we have to preserve them in
order not to kill every year an animal
in order to exhibit it here so we
thought about the preservation methods
of
chemistry actually talking about dead
birds is not that you know as as an
environmentalist I thought it's maybe
not that positive so I thought about the
third uh thing about birds uh and this
is very personal I think because I love
to watch Birds um and these days like
the the the tip of the of the spear is
the um are the um Birds of Prey right
like the the hunters the
Raptors and these days today in Germany
like the biggest raptor is basically our
um heraldic animal right the the the
eagle these days we have roughly 600 50
breeding pairs in Germany so even in
Berlin the capital of of of Germany you
can see um
Eagles when I was a kid or approximately
almost 50 years ago there were it was
almost extinct there were no Eagles in
Germany and there were obviously this is
a positive development over the last 50
years and there are many many different
reasons for it but one of them has to do
with chemistry and was a major one and
this was this one this
molecule is insecticide it's called
DDT and um it was bent in 1993 because
scientists discovered that the DDT that
kills insects those insects are eaten by
bigger animals those bigger animals are
then eaten at some point at the tip of
of the food chain Chain by the Raptors
by Eagles and what happens then is when
they lay their eggs the shell of the
eggs becomes thinner and thinner and
thinner ma making the breeding success
of the
birds basically not a success anymore so
the the number were declining so in 1992
based on those scientific findings it
was bent in in Germany and in 2004 it
was banned worldwide and since then we
see a dramatic increase in Birds
especially in seagulls so my hypothesis
is not only that chemistry is everywhere
but chemistry is very important if we
want to protect our planet
uh so giving you that little bonding to
where we are birds in chemistry today I
want to interact the first time with you
guys um I want to ask you one question
and I want you now to pull out your
smartphone and answer the following
question what are your
feelings towards
chemistry what are your feelings towards
CH what do you feel about when you hear
the word chemistry when you think about
it what do you you
feel so please scan it with your QR
Scanner you will then see like a text
box and then write down your feelings
give it like one and a half two
minutes and then once those one and a
half two minutes are gone we will we
will have a joint look towards the
results but not yet first of all scan
it and then think about your
feelings
very uncommon to talk about feelings
okay here comes the first results nine
people are typing in 13 people that's
good anyone does anyone need the QR code
no okay so anyone's
typing yep
okay nine people are still typing you
can you can have various
words oh there's the QR code too cool
that's that's
nice okay potential
hope five per five people are
typing toxic okay yeah might come to my
because of my example right but that's
fine
yeah okay three p okay let's let's have
a short summary what do do what do we
see here um excitement Fascination okay
potential so very
positive um hopeful creative but we also
see lots of netive things right toxic
afraid scary um
doubtful um
dangerous curiosity okay something of
both
incredible Yeah so basically we we have
mixed feelings here right I see mixed
feelings and uh I want to basically we
are here not a representative ative
number of people from Germany but I have
a study that shows the results and so I
want you to switch back to the to the
presentation thank you so I now want to
show you not the results but I want if
who is interested in this is a study
from The reinold Institute um published
in 2001 who were investigating the
question I was posing you a little bit
more detailed right but we're basically
discovering um two things um first of
all the feeling to from chemistry after
the second world war changed from being
that is that is giving us growth
Innovation Prosperity a positive feeling
about Innovation and growth right
towards nowadays it is um an
environmentally um destroying discipline
so it's very negtive negatively
perceived these days and the trend is
increasing so people are like the
broader public is perceiving chemistry
according to this study a Renown study
uh as being an environmental destroyer
and I'm not greenwashing here um there
are many many examples as DDT showed
right um that are harmful to us that are
toxic that are bad so totally agree and
whoever have seen this movie you know
I'm I love movies uh who ever seen this
this is a movie about a real thing that
happened about the Teflon scander by uh
dupon c one of the big
American Chemical
corporations it's it's it's not old
right it's in the 2000s in the beginning
of the 2000s and me myself I I was an
entrepreneur in the in in the chemical
industry what fascinated me the feeling
when watching that movie was very
accurate so being in and being in
chemical industry it is very opaque it
is very not transparent everyone Smiles
at you but behind your back people are
you know giving you the knife into your
back so and I think this is what we have
to change it's not only a technology
change what what I will talk about today
but it is also a cultural change we need
to be on eye level we need to face the
negative impacts and this means for you
being two3 not being related to
chemistry please never ever perceive
something as only being bad right
there's always another side of it only
you know claiming that chemistry is bad
will not do any good yeah will not do
any good we need to we need to better
understand what do you think is bad okay
this is truly bad what can we do in
order to change it and we need curiosity
we need people that go into and tap into
the field of chemistry because nowadays
what I perceive is they're either phds
in chemistry 80% who do a PhD uh who do
the field of chemistry P pursue a PhD
afterwards so either you meet someone
who's really deeply into it and having a
PhD or 98% of people I meet are saying
oh no chemistry that's the that's the
evil thing I hate it in school and I
really I'm not into it at all so this is
no balance here if we want to see
Innovations we need all disciplines even
from from social science even from from
other cultural uh from other disciplines
we need people interested in chemistry
not being afraid of tapping into it not
being afraid of asking question like
okay that sounds fascinating please
explain more to me right so this is this
is my take on it um when it comes to to
chemistry so why is it important to talk
about chemistry and go into this detail
well first of all it's because of our
planet right this is Mother Mother Earth
we have to protect it it's such a
beautiful this is Earthwise shot in 68
and it really made everyone of us clear
it's such a endangered little planet and
we are basically you know we are not we
not really taking care of this planet
right there are many many examples uh
you're I'm sure you're aware of it um
but one number summarize it that for me
because the picture must look like this
this is the so-called Earth overshot Day
some of you might heard of which says
like we are consuming the resources of
our planet as if we would have 1.7
planets and this the opposite of being
sustainable right and if we only look at
Germany and the Western countries this
number would go up to 3.5 so Germany
alone consumes resources as if we would
have 3.5 planets if we take that average
to all countries All
Humans so I'm not arguing chemistry can
do that alone we need all efforts right
we need also consumer behaviors right we
talking about vegetarian uh um dietary
and so on so we need to change on our
personal level but also in all other
different fields and chemistry and
especially chemistry in Germany in my
opinion has very high responsibility why
well first of all we are number two uh
we are really good in doing research
number two in Nobel prizes in chemistry
so we are really good in Germany
with 80 million people only in
discovering new discoveries new
scientific findings in chemistry yeah
furthermore we are really huge industry
220 billion industry number three in the
world measured by sales right with 80
million people so we know a lot we make
a lot of money but more importantly
almost all touchable products have have
at least one chemical synthesis step
there's a study saying 97% of of all
tangible products of our daily life have
at least one chemical reaction step
right so if we want to change that
picture to 1.0 planets or I would argue
0.9 planets because we have to give
Mother Earth a little rest yeah to
recover to re to heal chemistry must
play a role right but where do we stand
well in Industry
87% of all fossil of all resources used
are fossil based we living in a linear
industry disposing everything not
thinking about recycling it and taking
the resource base from
fossils so there's a long long way ahead
of us the good thing is H the good thing
is um we have the so-called 12
principles of green chemistry we have
some rules some guidance some examples
some yeah principles um that help
chemist and chemical Engineers to
develop products that are sustainable
that are not toxic following the
rules discovered by this very good
friend a mentor also like the name Giver
of my house uh from America professor
John Warner who together with the
colleague of his this well wrote down 25
years ago those 12 principles of
chemistry and he himself uh discovered
30 uh 350 patterns spin out over uh uh
nine spin outs in order to make this
findings and reach
count but now so I think everyone is
aware of chemistry is
everywhere and we have a rule of
changing that but let me tell you one
thing this so-called Chim that the
change of how we do chemistry not fossil
based renewable uh thinking in recycling
Loops being non-toxic being
degradable this is a dramatic change
this is nothing that is easily done done
right and this is what I call or what
science calls a disruptive change it is
not an incremental Innovation it's not
something minor we we built it is
something we have to change
fundamentally and what can we learn from
it uh first of all I want to make you a
little bit more awareness of what is a
disruption and I want to use an analogy
an analogy to my second desire which is
sports I love sports yeah and when I was
a little boy I was always watching with
my parents Sports and one of the things
we were watching especially in winter
time was ski jumping and you know
looking back at those times when I was
10 years old everyone was jumping like
this it's the so-called parallel style
some of you might remember the younger
the young of you might will both
probably
not then in 190 86 there comes a Swedish
guy and he was really bad at jumping he
was not even Midfield he was like always
like in lower rankings and he came up
with a uh with a style that is now
called The V style and if you watch Ski
Jumping nowadays everyone jumps like
this but in Ski Jumping it is um when
it's not on the one who wins is not the
one who jumps the furthest but they were
also graded yeah you receive 20 points
if it looks beautiful if it doesn't look
beautiful how you land and how you fly
and so on you got degraded by like 18
seconds and so on and so on like zero
points is the lost and when he
introduced The V style in 86 the first
time he got degraded heavily he received
six points instead of 20 Four Points in
set of and he was never winning a
tournament in the first year even though
he was jumping further than all his
colleagues so and this I can really
remember there was a big debate going on
and it took like two or three years
until everyone understood okay there's a
logic behind mind he jumps like this he
has highest surface with the highest
surface you can fly further so other
competitors adapted to it and you saw
like the next year three other people
were jumping the next year after like 10
people were jumping like this and so
there was a real big debate going on and
this is what I call and nowadays
everyone is jumping like this there's no
uh degradation of jumping like this I
would argue if someone would would fly
like this today they will get degraded
yeah and this is what I call a
disruptive innovation it changes the
rules of the game yeah and whoever and
whoever wants to understand and gets a
feeling how hard it is to find or to to
implement something that is truly
better into a world that says well I
don't like it please watch that movie
The concussion protocol also true events
shows you like um the fight of this
doctor
medicine AR doctor a doctor who um
discovered uh like in in the in the
football that when people when the
players hit their their heads that they
they receive micr lesions and when they
get older they get really bad
diseases and discovering something
discovering the truth truth as a
scientist and fighting against the
biggest sport organization a fight you
didn't want you didn't pick yourself it
was given to you by a scientific finding
this was really a good example how hard
it is to change something even if you
believe it's true you know it's true but
you have to convince all the others and
and this gives you like a feeling about
how hard it is to really accomplish
disruptive
change okay obviously there's also a
science behind it right you can this is
a sports analogy but you can take this
towards business towards technology
development and so on and but and this
is what theory tells us right you can
over the time you can you can plot the
technology performance like parallel
jumping yeah they were like kind of at
the end they couldn't jump further with
the technique then bulo came and he was
jumping with the V style and they could
clearly jump further but very
importantly is this intersection here at
the beginning he was not jumping further
the first two 300 jumps were not further
than the parallel die so it took some
time in order to climb up you know this
learning curve and overcome the old
technology and this is one of the
characteristics that the new technology
is lower performing yet it has a higher
potential so this is the this is the the
area where discontinuity begins where
the fight of what is better what is
worse really leads to arguments and
leads to beliefs rather than
proofs and this is one important
characteristic of disruptive innovation
you have to understand the second one I
want to highlight with another example
coming closer to business the ship
industry back in the days people were
sailing right and then Innovative guy
came around the corner made an
incremental Innovation and say like why
do we sail only with one Mast let's make
this let take two then another guy came
well let's let's do this right and then
let's do this and then okay let's be
really crazy let's do this
yeah and what happens then is not a six
MTH then it comes then comes this
disruption takes
place and what is important here to
understand is that the capabilities of
putting masks on sailing boats and
coordinating the people on the Sailing
Boat is one thing and it's very
complicated thing no doubt about it but
those capabilities are not at all needed
when using a steam
vessel so disruption has one thing at
the
beginning the performance is a theor and
at the same time the capabilities you
need in order to execute the disruptive
technology are others are different than
the ones of the highly excelled
technology currently being
deployed and those are two
characteristics of my main point when
you look in industry and that is
observed over many many many many
industries by Clayton Christensen he
discovered or he calls it disruptive
innovation theory he discovered over
many industries that the disruptive
Innovations have never been
found by the dominant players but by new
entrance the digital photography was not
invented by Kodak and AKA right
Wikipedia was not discovered or not
implemented by Brock house and so on and
you can find many examples like Tesla
was not invented by Volkswagen BM BMW or
Mercedes right so this is very important
when we talking about disruptive
innovation about the change in the game
about doing things completely
differently we need new entrance we need
new players and this is my point first
of all I think green chemistry is
changing the game and second of all I
think it is new players that will lead
that change according to Theory yeah
that is my
hypothesis so and this is why and now I
make make like the loop what my job is
I'm the coordinator of green cam what is
green cam green cam is the Innovation
ecosystem for Innovations in green
chemistry I bring together the three
universities in Berlin TFA all of them
having faculties of chemistry and to
Industry players in order to achieve one
thing Innovations do disrupt the way we
do chemistry from teaching from
researching and most importantly of
bringing Innovation to Market because in
chemistry we need products that are
sustainable that are not harming Our
Lives um that are recycable that are
based on Renewables rather than fossils
and so on and this is basically the
goal um around us we have set up an
so-called ecosystem so partners that are
relevant for innovation in chemistry
like like yeah um small mediumsized
Enterprises big Enterprises
facilitators um also uh bundas so
federal agencies of Environmental
Protection because in chemistry it's an
industry that is highly regulated and
with regulation you can either hinder
new uh Innovations or facilitate new
Innovations and they and they want to
understand and support to understand how
how can they do the trick and obviously
also VC so the capital SCS also engaged
so what is the mission of of green cam
right the green cam oh very importantly
I have to say thank you first of all uh
to you guys and all to all German
taxpayers because we received 10 million
euros over the next 10 day 10 years from
uh the Federal Ministry of research and
education in order to set this ecosystem
running um we had the kickoff almost
four weeks ago uh officially started in
March this year so thanks to all
taxpayers um to to give me that money as
the coordinator I promise you I will
spend it very wisely for for the right
things um that's at least how I take it
um so what is the what is the mission
yeah picture can say more than thousand
words so the the the metaphor of the
mission is we are building a bridge a
bridge between the chemical research and
the market right in order to facilitate
findings in uh green chemistry res
research making it towards the market
because as I said we need products that
we can buy that we can use that are
better than the current ones yeah so
that's basically the idea uh and
obviously such a bridge is not no one
way it is also a way towards research so
we want to engage with corporations with
startups that are already implemented in
the market and want to understand where
are your sustainability issues where is
your current product not yet sustainable
it is maybe involved mentally seen
better but it's not yet there it's not
yet fully recyclable it's not not yet
where we supposed to be and that's
exactly I think where research can also
contribute in order to enhance um
sustainability of a
product um well and then now comes the
question maybe some of you okay
chemistry in
Berlin that doesn't sound that doesn't
feel right Berlin is not supposed to be
like the chemical hotspot right if you
look where is the chemical hotspot is
somewhere lusen right vatal and like
where the Rin is right there are many
many chemical sites that's where the
chemistry in Germany um is happening not
though in Berlin but I say actually
that's our advantage we have several
advantages here in Berlin first of all
um basically we have the mindset we have
lots of young people who are arguing the
way how we're currently consuming and
and having products is not not how we
supposed to have it in 10 or 20 years
from now we have to change
sustainability is you know like with uh
Fridays for future the the climate
activist and so on we are really in the
capital of Germany we are arguing and we
have to keep doing that right we're not
yet there so uh I think the mindset is
one thing um second of all the research
uh we have a lots and lots of research
institution but most of all I would say
we don't have have the historic
baggage we we don't see the chemical
sides we don't have the arguments of
saying well this is not working because
then I have to you know deconstruct
everything and so we have no such thing
we we are basically we can go from
scratch and this is one of the big
Advantage but nevertheless and this is
also one of the advantages I'm working
on in
chemistry it's about you know it's a
very practical science you do need
laboratory you do need scaleup
facilities you do need to do the product
and this is something where we also at
Berlin what we composed and we set up um
under the umbrella of green cam is
unique no one has that in all over
Germany and this is with regard to the
infrastructure um and there I want to
introduce this the last concept then we
are finished for like lecture part this
is the last uh uh concept I want to
introduce which is like the technology
Readiness level the TRL basically
invented by the NASA when they were
flying to the Moon yeah it was a big
project so they chunk the project into
nine steps of Technology
development yeah so let me explain so
when you do research now you're going
into laboratory with your professor you
do research crazy things and all of a
sudden you discover
something you're still TRL zero it's not
even TRL one it's just a scientific
finding but if you take that scientific
finding write down on a piece of paper
the idea of how that scientific finding
can make a contribution to the market to
our daily lives how you can create the
business around that then you have an
idea then you have tier
L1 right and if you climb up the ladder
of Technology development you at the
ultimate you produce with that IDE
product that you sell to the market that
is really implemented in the market that
is the last step and if you look and I
said we have an advantage in terms of
infrastructure if you look at um at yeah
at at the infrastructure um um um uning
uh
dependencies uh criteria sorry requ
requirements thank you that's you know
very very very good um uh then you can
um separate in between four different
steps regarding like how like reaction
volume whatever but how much mass of
product you're producing like in the
first four trls it's about okay taking
that idea and finding out the borders
like how far can I go what are key um
applications what are the requirements
for those U um um applications and then
you want to wiggle your idea your
scientific finding into the room of fre
free um uh operating window so to speak
and basically you do that in very small
amounts yeah you do not want to burn
lots of product or lots of material you
do that in laboratory scale grams a few
grams then at the end and you come up
okay you find your first customer and
they say well that's interesting and at
a certain point the customer says to you
okay I want a kilogram I want to test
your material I want to see whether this
is really working in my application and
then you're talking about the kilogram
once the let's assume the the customer
the potential is happy and says okay we
want to order 10 tons of you per year
you not go into full production you
prepare production uh into like this 100
kg area and then once that is that is
fixed you then execute production
depending on your product in the size
and what we have here in Berlin this is
unique we basically have every step
every infrastructure requirement you can
imagine first of all we have what I'm
leading the John Warner Center for
startups in green chemistry the chemic
menion factory as well as the incab we
have infrastructure Laboratory um that
is at the T Berlin offering space for
preed early stage spin up projects
yeah also in at the iris alas it's a
research facility opens up the doors for
startups that that have the necessity
for their infrastructure then for the
next range we can go up to 150 liters in
the scal up lab of Professor Rina hak at
the F Berlin then one of our partners
opens up their so-called technicum like
up to th liter and then we have all um
the areas where you can really locate um
your production in the area of berin so
basically when you're a researcher when
you have something when you have a
pattern and and you want to bring it to
Market we have not only the ecosystem
and you know the Feelgood Factor but we
have also the very highly costly
infrastructure build in order to support
you and last but not least we are not
talking about just an idea yeah we have
build it about the last I'm into the
startup scenes since 2011 with my own
two spin outs I'm now at University as
I'm always saying I'm an entrepreneur
who went back to University in order to
help the Next Generation do an easier
and a better job than I did um and this
is the result of uh basically 12 years
of of work um to really put up uh a
community of startups from different uh
not only Fields but only also different
stages of their lifetime from being very
very very early just having an idea we
want to do something up until once which
I will welcome like wild on a stage for
really further right up until people
that are really already selling big big
volumes and this is what happens right
if you have those exchange between I
have an idea and someone who knows how
to execute then I I think it can
flourish and this um yeah is what our
vision is what John said he thinks that
berin can become the Silicon Valley
inred green chemistry startups and
really that Innovations in the field of
green chemistry to all of our benefits
for us as Society for our planet
hopefully uh can will come from Berlin
that's at least what we are working
for so far uh for me well yeah that's
basically bracket so to speak yeah um so
again I love what I do I do what I laugh
not only privately but also I have a
very big privilege of receiving that
amount of money in order to set the up
to combine three universities to combine
38 startups and growing numbers and to
invite people and my narrative is very
easy the older generation and I consider
myself you know in that range I'm
getting older and older um so we kind of
up with the planet right we
messed it up um and disrup of innovation
Theory tells
us you better do not bet on us right you
better do not bet on the old Pals
we need the Young Generation and green
Cam and all the partners are willing to
give all the support free of charge no
equity taken no no shares taken in order
to bring your ideas or the ideas of your
friends towards Market in order to
increase our all lives and and the
planet's life so this is uh this is I
think what what we what we are striving
for to make like this picture count and
give the mother earth a little rest
so far from my side I'm now open for any
questions first of all to the talk if
there are none are there any questions
first of
all yeah there's one question do we have
a mic so that people in the Ah that's
me yeah it's on
Thana okay thank you for your talk just
a brief question when you talk about
chemistry does this include life
sciences like drug develop M
pharmaceutics and and stuff like this
which are very different things like
like you need clinical studies and and
so on is this included in
chemistry um
so yes it is kind of um so I always
saying like I have we have only two
requirements very good that you told me
that word I needed it so we have only
two requirements that you're um that you
are welcome in green cam first of on
your Innovation must have a positive
impact on planet so if you're
pharmaceutical says okay the ones
currently in Market are accumulating in
nature and are causing like theing of of
the shell of birds for
instance my Innovation isn't there's a
clear benefit for the planet first check
and second check is can we really
contribute with our infrastructure so
the laboratory the scale up and so on as
well as the ecosystem around it can we
really contribute to your success and
this is the second check and if both are
there if both are green lights you're
happily welcome so that's that's the
first part so I'm I love I do love
chemistry but for me
that's there is for me there's no fight
between chemistry and biotechnology
approaches right I think we need both
and only relying on one is stupid so we
need to rely on both but if we have some
biotechnology approach es our uh
laboratory infrastructure is not made
for this unfortunately we're really
focusing on chemistry um Innovations
which is why the requirements like
certain types of fum hoods we do not
have so we cannot
contribute but if you're uh if you're
talking about lime Sciences having a
small molecule a chemical synthesized
molecule I would argue yes it is um but
also saying uh charite uh with their
incubation program also do have a very
valid uh um ecosystem around so yeah
that's like maybe a little vague but
let's talk about if you have an
innovation let's talk about um and if we
are not the ones and or we are really
well connected we can open doors and and
and guide it to the right persons that's
at least uh it's not about us it's about
making the planet better and then
pinpointing you to the right
persons other questions there I see
one hey um has there been an innovation
lately that you yourself found like
especially exciting yeah totally I mean
everyone really there are so so many
things it would be very very um unfair
to pinpoint one but I give you one um I
give you one one thing I'm really
curious about because the the thing is
not on the slide yet but I'm working on
it um it comes from from Israel our
friends in Israel making a tough time at
the moment um so they have discovered uh
um a technology
where they can basically capture CO2
that is bound in in the in water and
bind it with the ions um in the water
towards a solid phase so and basically
that solid phase that uh carbonate
it is you can then sell as a product and
uh and so it's really it's doing two
things it's capturing CO2 from the
atmosphere via the water right so the
water gets the CO2 to back from
Atmosphere by itself you don't have to
do a thing um and then you bound it
towards a product and bound it there
forever and the order of magnitude
they're they're envisioning and they
like the results from really like
highest signs are super promising so
I'm you know the the carbon dioxide
threat it is there but I think we have
Solutions so we do have Solutions there
that are not yet marketable but I had
say say like in 10 15 years from from
now or even beforehand um we will see
dramatic decline in CO2 uh concentration
atmosphere due to those Technologies and
that makes me really really promising
and really excited about it to help
now cool so then we have a lat Q&A
session um now you had a lot of talk
about my I didn't talk about my startups
because that's not about me let's hear
it from some of our startups which is
wild I don't want to make the pitch for
you Stephanie I welcome you on stage you
get the second mic and please introduce
your
startup yes hi thank you for having me
my name is Stephanie uh I work with wild
uh we are a company from Berlin based in
Berlin founded in Berlin in 2021 as a
profit forp purpose company um which
means that we do not only think our
products as a circular thing but also
our economy as a circular thing and uh
that we see a lot of benefit from
keeping everything in the circle in the
loop and uh thinking of everything as a
connected thing so what do we do uh we
produce um products made from seaweed
that are mainly absorbent products or in
the overall Universe in the algers we
see the absorbent products based on
seaweed fibers or non-fiber
applications and um our first product is
the kpon I have it here so it's a
seaweed based tampon that is um meant to
also break the stigma around uh tampons
to um create a product that leads to a
more sustainable way of producing tampon
period products also other absorbent
products like um diapers baby diapers um
also incontinance material material in
the long run um but also that empowers
people to um yeah talk openly about
issues to also see um what they can do
to their health by just using more
health-friendly products than the
conventional products and um yeah we
have a bunch of things to do um I think
we will go further into this uh in the
Q&A session later so this is just a
brief presentation of
wild cool thank you thank you very
much so now now it's like we thought
about giving it some credibility of
having a what I was told as a format of
discussion or exchange which is a
fireside chat and we will get two
chairs on stage in a fire hopefully not
not good
yeah and then yeah just just have a
short discussion
about um your experiences as joining
that you joined you told me in February
this year right yes um so you're not
there from the very first beginning
nevertheless I I suppose it was a really
steep learning C for you it was yes yeah
so um what you have figured out what is
um what is your motivation why did you
join what did you learn from the from
the founders what is their m motivation
of doing it and where do you see the
alignment with the 12 principles of
chemistry um well first of all I think I
already joined because I found the idea
of producing really Innovative products
menstral products um I found that idea
like overwhelming because I feel like
the menstral market is one that has not
been touched since it had been created
so I mean yeah the health been some some
developments but um what I think is that
it's super important to have
non-reusable products that are still
healthy and um good for nature because
um in the end if you don't tackle that
problem if half of the population
menstruates then it's a big problem if
you only produce waste but you can't um
rely on everybody being able to for
example use reusable products so um yeah
this was one one thing that led me
to uh yeah write my application for wild
actually and um what I also find very
interesting is that um both enas and
Melly um the founders of wild um are
able to really rethink things so as you
mentioned earlier it's like you want to
learn from the young people and I think
they have the ideas they have the drive
they have also like the ability to see
what's possible and what kind kind of
environment and how can we change the
environment in order to reach our goal
so to go further and I think um that
yeah this is also what combines us that
like taking together all of our energy
all all our levels uh that can bring us
forward cool so it's it's really purpose
and I I know the two Founders
obviously I think they as you described
and it's really good to see also another
powerful woman yeah and putting the
finger into the wound where where we you
know not supposed to talk about and
really I think that's where you know
where Innovation take place so whenever
you guys see a field of in your life
where you think okay actually no one
talks about that this might be very very
interesting so cool so uh with regard to
the 12 principles what what would you
say what is your what what is your take
or Wild's take on on it um we have
different takes I think because um one
thing that we see that is also leading
to a health problem um in the chemistry
of conventional period products is that
um it's not regenerative so it's not
biodegradable or not degradable without
the bio even it's not degradable so it
PS up and um yeah gets out in the world
and just PS up um and the the other take
is that um we want to reduce
significantly reduce the use of
pollutants throughout the process
because we are still creating a man-made
fiber for example by using chemistry but
actually by using Greener chemistry so
it's a water-based process that um also
the extraction of the raw material is
much less harmful in the whole life
cycle of the raw material but also in
the end of the whole product so these
are like the main points that I want to
point out now so Circ circularity
circularity like the renewable feed
stock and also the the synthesis or the
Tre no it's not the but the treatment of
the raw materials in water-based process
that's yes yeah cool that's uh so that's
I think it's very important to
understand no innovation touches all 12
principles right I see here three
principles touched and if you would if
you would discuss with John with his 350
uh patn he would always say like those
patents none of them have has touched
more than three principles it's not
about touching all of them but taking
them as a guidance and yeah cool um so
yeah sustainability benefits I think we
talked about or would you add something
towards
it of your product of your of your well
I can talk a lot about sustainab ility
benefits of our product yeah do that
that's cool um well we have different
aspects of sustainability so for example
if you take the raw material when you
com compare it to the conventional
material that is being used so um if we
use seaweed we have a material that is
naturally grown in the ocean so it
doesn't need fresh water it doesn't need
fertilizers it doesn't need uh any
pesticides whatever
um it's rather on the opposite that it
is able to um counteract the acid
acidification of the oceans and while
growing it also
um it it it
um
Le delivers thank you it it delivers an
ecosystem where um fish can grow where
other species can grow so the whole
thing is um while we grow our raw
material we can also grow the
environment and this is like really
circular thinking and I mean of course
this is always a question of scale of
course because if I outscale it and I
overrun the whole ecosystem and the
algae is not able to regrow in a in a
sufficient manner then I will have the
3.5 again but
if I can um like restore a certain part
of the algae forest and I can um take
out some of the raw material then I can
get to the
0.9 so um this is one part that is
really important to me and I know also
to Enos and Mellie so um
yeah but current do I I'm not sure but
do you uh do you plan on on on
cultivating your own seaweed for your
own production or is currently buying
from producers which I suppose is at the
moment like kind of a bottleneck or
isn't it a
bottleneck it is kind of a bottleneck
actually it wouldn't have to be but the
industry is like really slow and um
there are big players that really
dominate the market and it's kind of
hard to uh get to other sources but um
we are currently focusing on um sourcing
local seaweed or raw material made from
seaweed and um our idea is that's why we
also um keep in touch with science
people um with universities with you
guys um that we are also looking into
how can we make the sourcing so
efficient that for example we are not
bound to one species of algae so that we
can Source whatever comes for example to
the beach there's a lot of seaweed being
uh brought to the beach just naturally
so is there a possibility of sourcing
that kind of raw material which is right
now not the case because we're still in
the hygiene sector and we have to comply
with certain requirements and stuff like
that of course it's very important
because it's contributing directly to
our health the menstruators health um
but we think we're convinced that there
are other other possibilities that
still have not been thought and that we
have to put a lot of like
science
stuff I'm not going to say
the word um no that we have to uh to put
a lot of brain work into developing this
whole chain in a more Greener way and
yeah cool um
so I touched it a little bit about you
know being
in in our markets you're startups are
usually touched by regulations heavily
so what what can you tell us about the
challenges you know coming from seaweed
is more in the food market I I suppose
or some of us might know it um but
coming into a non- food market into the
market you're in what are the challenges
so to speak um well one of the main
challenges is um the existing market so
the dominant
uh parties in the menstrual care product
Market um because of course this is a
price driven sector and if you come um
into the market with a new raw material
that is of course not being sourced in
such a over sourcing way so the price is
higher of course because the price gets
lower the more you Source I don't know
how that makes sense but it's it's the
market and um so you come in with
something that is being sourced in a
sustainable way and everybody is like
well but you're never going to hit the
price and then we have to
convince others that it's still possible
to hit the price or to hit a reasonable
price because maybe the price
is should be different because the price
we pay is in money is low but for health
for example it's not low so so there are
a lot of residuals in the in um product
I don't want to scare you please they're
still being tested they're still cool to
use but um we think there is a lot of
um space to Home Improvement yeah yeah
space to
Improvement okay
so I talked a little bit about the
startups and the startup environment um
so looking at maybe the audience and
also the people watching us what kind of
advice would you give when people think
about doing something on their own
starting up
something what what are your learnings
what what what can you advise from your
learnings personal ones um well the
learnings I saw since working at Wild
which is not such a long time but still
I had like really a lot of learnings and
one main thing is that it is so so
important to believe in your own ideas
and to find out why you think that those
ideas can work and then find partners
that maybe think alike and those
Partners you can find them anywhere so
you can find them in other for example
small companies and other startups but
you can also find them in big players
that are just not in the spot to do the
invention themselves so you find people
people who you can talk to and it's
always crucial to always um not lose the
focus because we are still part of the
whole industry of course we're still
trying to disrupt the industry by
bringing in a new raw material so we
still have to work um within the
boundaries that are given by the
industry and yeah for example what you
do uh is we benefit a lot from that that
you offer this kind of guidance to bring
in global players to bring in big
factories big companies I mean and um
bring them together with the smaller uh
entrepreneurs who are having the ideas
in order to um how do you say um to
to
um the hurdles yeah to decrease their
hurdles to lower the barriers yes cool I
mean we we touched about it a little bit
earlier private session uh but uh I
think it's very important that you know
the the importance of eye level you know
talking on eye level can you can you
explain a little what I mean or what we
mean by that what why is this so
important and what what do you take on
it yes um this is super important
because also like if we as wild as a
quite small company talk to Big players
um we always see it as
um we're not collaborating projectwise
but we're trying to find partners that
we can rely on and that they also are
interested in what we have to say so
that we always look for people be it the
big companies be it the small companies
or just friends advisors whoever um that
will also have a positive impact from
working with us so it's not we of course
we have questions and of course we want
to ask questions and have an open
discussion but this is the point we want
want to have an open discussion and not
be the ones that are just like okay we
have a cool idea ah you say it doesn't
work okay well then let's just skip it
because that's not how you disrupt
something yeah so it's kind of finding
the leverage between um we want to put
our ideas up front but at the same time
we see that it's really important to
also listen to the others like why are
they doing this in a certain way and why
hasn't it been changed so maybe we can
like skip this yeah cool so it's you
know it's about skepticism obviously in
startups you also have skepticism you
don't know whether it's working or not
but you work very constructively with it
so ey level means I think is expressing
the skepticism between each other but
then approaching not on the netive down
this is not working why but ah this
might be interesting let's let's try it
out
yeah and and not you know tear each
other down but let you know like okay
this sounds interesting why not and I
think also to find out where do
skepticism comes from to to as you said
before there are many people who say oh
chemistry is bad okay but if you don't
tell me why you think that chemistry is
bad then we can tackle that problem but
if you open and openly discuss why you
have those those thoughts those
um um I'm for Tor advantages that's
fine um we're talking fun here yes um
then we can work with that and then we
can find workarounds or improvements or
yeah create something new together cool
so last two questions and I would open
up to the to the crowd um so I talked a
lot about you know disruptive
Innovations and why do we need startups
yeah I hopefully explain it quite well I
don't know but um you being an a startup
an entrepreneur you know being one of
those entities that says okay we don't
accept that we want to change what is
your take on on on disruptive change on
bringing products to Market like what
how do you see your own role uh as a
startup entrepreneur in in disruptive
change um that is a very wide question
wild question a wild question um um how
do we see our own role I think
um what we do is that we are still small
enough to innovate things that have
always been done like that so we still
have the
creativity and the
um like we're looking for something new
and we want to develop forward MH and
and
um and you told me beforehand like kind
of you're aware of that disruptive step
you have to take but that might be a
little bit too big to take at once yes
and you have being aware means also okay
looking where is the point of making one
step towards it of achieving it so it's
finding a balance that is also what I uh
tried to say before that you always have
to look at the existing processes like
um what are the key points
that need to be changed like
immediately and what are the points that
are not easily going to be changed so
how can I find my way into the process
with my new idea so don't change
everything all at once because of course
that won't work then you have to build
your own industry and easy be creative
be smart right
always cool okay then only like the last
question you know you're working on on a
on a product that one could potentially
buy or can we already buy that product
where can we buy it and what's next what
are your future plans um actually this
kpon is still the beta version that had
been uh used also in our consumer trial
so um we have gotten the feedback from
men trators um towards this product that
we kind of invented and then we kind of
created how we want to do it and now
we've gotten the feedback from the
consumer trial and this feedback is
currently being processed into our next
product the Gen one um kpon that is
ready to Market uh by beginning of next
year cool yes so we're currently in the
production cycle and we're working
strongly in the back uh to make
everything work and to get in all the
improvements that we see from the
feedback we gotten from the consumer
trial um that we see our still necessary
and what we also think for ourselves we
find necessary and um yep what you can
do is uh you can subscribe uh to the
waiting list so as soon as the kpon is
ready um you will have it flying to your
doorstep and um also if you are
interested in our mission and you want
to get involved you can also head to our
uh web page uh which is wildness de it's
not the easiest
but I you'll make it you Google it yes
you Google it and um yeah we have we are
looking for uh new talents so maybe
you're interested or maybe you want to
support us in a different way then
always head to the web page and find out
also more about profit profit for
purpose companies and Steward ownership
which is the other circular part of our
company where we try to
interpret uh economic models in a new
modern more sustainable in a circular
way thank you cool it's really it's a
pleasure to have you here you're a great
team great product I really looking
forward to see that coming to the market
uh also you know team is growing success
brings more work brings more products
brings new employees so good luck with
that um I'm GL I'm really honored and
now I would yeah ask the crowd do you
have any questions so stefhanie what
yeah what are your
questions yeah there's one the mic is
coming
too hey uh I I'm not sure if I catch
that right in the beginning that you
also are about to do like diapers and
other materials um and is it also beta
version right now or is that something
for the future when when you're cool
with a temple at the market um we had
one small diaper project where um but
that was a collaboration with another
company a German company called gold
imer um and we co-developed a diaper
inlay that is fully bio compostable not
biodegradable but compostable and um
there we tested the first type of algae
based inlay for the absorbent core in
order to overcome the super absorbers
that are currently in the diaper
and um for now we have to concentrate on
the kpon we would like to develop
everything all at once because it's
super exciting but um obviously you
can't do that because then everything
will just be halfway and uh as far as I
can say the diaper is probably going to
be the next great big
product there was another question just
beside hey um I got two questions the
first one is if do you think this kind
of raw material can be used in other
applications like packaging or
construction materials in your
experience working with this raw
material and the other one it's about
the regulations because this is a type
of product that is used on the body so
how can you ass make sure that H in the
long term it has no consequences or have
a side effect and how do you manage to
work with the people that makes the
regulation for this kind of products M
thank you for both questions
um the regulation thing first um there
are lots of regulations um that are
quite strict for uh the health benefits
and um the seaweed based fibers have
been used before in medical applications
as well so there is a long history of
safe use it just has not been used in um
consumer products because regulations
are so high and um yeah people want to
use cheaper cheaper raw materials that's
kind of the said end of the story um but
this is how of course we're going to
have more consumer trials because this
is also something that we are looking
into we are also working together with
with other universities in order to um
do the
proper
biocompatibility tests and in order to
uh really show that this is not a
harmful product and now I forgot the
first question I'm sorry other
applications of your material yeah um
yeah there are other applications
there's also uh one C family member the
muo lab um for example they're working
on on um alga based um um um packaging
packaging foils so foils and everything
like the real
plastic and um yep so there are a lot of
different use cases for the raw material
and also um like for example when you do
the extraction of the of the algae you
have different stages of um extracts so
it's not only one extract that comes out
because of course the algae is made of
more than just one component and so you
can use a lot of different components
for different areas of application and
also um for example there in the
personal care space there are being uh a
lot of products made with parts of
seaweed and
yeah cool maybe there are two questions
yeah okay so you've mentioned several
times that the product wouldn't be cheap
and how do you plan to convince people
to really use the product because I see
the problem that of course it's
sustainable but a lot of people say okay
well it's it is sustainable but I don't
like I don't have the money to buy the
expensive one and for me it's better to
use the cheaper one so yeah um we see
two different things here one is that
right now the scale for production of
the raw material from
um seaweed that is going to be used in a
non-fruit sector that is not a medical
application is like really low so by
creating products and we don't want to
be the only ones creating those products
but we want to like also have other
companies creating non-f food
applications of the seaweed raw material
um we create the certain kind of
Leverage so we have to stay on the edge
of over um over sourcing the raw
material but at the same time we can
increase the um
naag the demand the demand in a way that
also prices will drop because um there
will be more efficient processes for
example for extracting the raw material
because right now this is also
like depending on where you go but this
is also like quite ancient and the
efficiency of the plants is quite low
and stuff like that and this also um
raises the price of course of the raw
material and the other part is that um
we think that not only menator should be
paying for menal products but this
should be a load for everyone so we have
not figured out uh the fully the full
concept I think uh there are many people
thinking about a concept that could be
usable but um this is also a way of of
lowering the price in the end and making
it affordable for everyone because we
don't believe that the healthy product
should only be available for the rich
people but should be available for
everyone in best case for free but we
still
have yeah a long way to go okay so I
have a second question and and if the
demand of that product if that is a
sustainable idea and the demand will
rise and don't you think that it is
something like a seaweed is growing in
the ocean or in the sea and don't you
think by using a large amount of that we
are like um I don't know uh going into
his ecosystem and disturbing something
there yeah yeah that is a very good
question and that is what I mean by uh
overe extracting because um you don't
have to extract the whole plant in order
to uh gain the raw material so there are
different ways of
harvesting um also the harvesting of the
seaweed is already highly regulated so
that this over harvesting doesn't take
place but um what we're also working on
with another
University is um that we're trying to
find out how we could um
restore kelp forest
so how can we grow the kelp forest on
one side and on the other side like take
something out but in a way that it's
always still an environment for the
animals to live
in thanks and I hope it's going it will
be going well thank you there was also
one question in the back and like one
two and then let's but it's fine those
two question doesn't really matter about
them yeah you you you will po your
question but two more question and then
I think we hit the time limit because I
have also two questions it's very
interesting I I'm a little bit curious
what what are your plans with your with
your startup company do you want um if
it turns out to be a good idea do you
want to sell it by yourself which means
setting up a marketing sales and
everything or are your plans um to to
sell the whole stuff I mean you you
probably have patents to sell your
intellectual property to sell the
company to a bigger company that they
may produce it with certain risk that
they don't do it what I don't know
whether you want to answer this question
what what what are your plans so your
kind of business I would love to answer
this but this is currently like in the
developmental phase so we're still not
bound to one way and I think we will
never be bound to one way because we're
wild
and
um yeah that's cool this is uh it's also
very personal right it's it's a very
personal decision of each and every
founder which path to pursue but I
always say it's like you know like doing
what you love to do for the end of your
life it's nice but it plans change you
can sell something that's of value but
uh but I think one one thing that I can
say towards this is that as I said
before we don't care if we're the only
one producing this or if there are a lot
of small companies producing these kind
of products because what we see is the
benefit for us for the environment for
men Traders for like us as in the
society so if more people want to join
why not this is something very okay like
let's put it the last question and then
it turns out to be me can you can you
tell us a little bit you mentioned that
V wild is one of the companies that are
part of this sort of of incubation cycle
that you helped can you tell us a little
bit about what your interaction was with
them and how you helped them and and how
you were helped I mean I'm sure there's
two stories on on both sides like what
shall I answer that maybe yeah yes
because because you're you're pretty new
to the team I think wild wild is kind of
an exception because the idea was born
outside of the three University that
that that are partnering uh which I find
very I see that now more often coming
it's more from the uh uh product design
type of you know like experimenting with
materials and then going into like the
business model and the material side
rather than coming from chemistry from
the Material Science and then thinking
about the business right so uh what we
did we helped like in the very early
phases about characterization of the
material of what you said like having
different feed stocks where where are
the boundaries and there we uh we did
like thesis work scientific thesis work
together with professors and students
who accompanied the early phase
developments and now it's more like on
those events like this and exchanging
with more grownup teams and now like
wild is switching more into a role as
being an adviser to early phase teams
rather than receiving early phase advice
yeah because they're more I wouldn't say
grownup but they are very experienced in
in the like in the middle phase yeah
so cool so I would like cut the
questions from your end uh now I got two
more questions to you uh when we please
pull out your uh your mobile phones
because I want to pose that question
with
aido you've heard about one Innovation
and so please name any particular
sustainable Innovation or Innovations or
initiatives you're excited about or or
wish you or which you wish to see
developed in the near
future yeah so you all what I want the
background is you all come from an own
background I love fly fishing for
instance each and everyone has its own
background so go into your own
background and think about where do you
need an innovation where do you want to
see an innovation occurring in order to
change the current status quo in order
to be more
sustainable yeah so think about it POS
it this kind of a citizen science
approach we will take that and think
about with the chemistry community of
what is there what can we do and so
on yeah so what are the Innovations from
your particular point of view you wish
to see in the near
future so I don't see any
scanning so I would love to ask the
regie to show the results and I learned
there is also the QR code cool clothing
a nice
hygiene
products
yeah
diapers biobased chemicals that's
cool the fabric yeah coffee capsules
yeah cool substitution of plastic yeah
Airplane Fuel yeah the so-called saf
sustainable Aviation
fuels flying home biogas plant oh yeah
that's cool plant growing in cities
yeah res paper
options three more people
typing
okay carbon binding yeah that's cool we
working on
it thank you I see like the two more
people's typing who will take that so to
to get a uh a cloud of words and and
think about it digest it um and now I
would love to like go back to the
presentation mode and that's the last
thing of today your last Duty so to
speak uh good
yep like the last thing is another scan
because this was our first time here we
we never did that at Berlin science week
and we want to learn from you whether
you liked it where do you see
improvements and so on so please scan
this QR code and give us your feedback
on today's sessions there are several
questions uh so that we can improve and
then then that we can get better and
better and better so for this um we give
you like few minutes nevertheless I
would
love I see one more guy scanning it
that's
good um I would love to say thank you
please fill in the
questionnaire um thank you Stephanie it
was great to talk to you thank you thank
you for having me thanks the audience
for attending uh and yeah talk about
chemistry raise your your questions as
you said so yeah your concerns it's very
important uh that's we have to unfold
chemistry it has to come out of the dark
Zone into the green zone uh and I think
we have more more Innovations to come
cool thank you very much have a nice
evening